these questions are asking you alright
we've got something we want to measure
whole bunch of people of measurement or
I myself have measured it multiple
multiple times and then you take the
average okay now I think just let me
know on this first question all of the
measures are in this ballpark but
they're also the nearest what it is the
centimeters meters millimeters okay so
they're all to the nearest millimeter
yeah so what are the actual is used to
tell me because some people take them
they're gonna be some blood yet okay so
you get there so in other words and in
fact I'll use the other side the
instrument that we're working with is
clearly to the nearest millimeter that's
all the accuracy that we really have
okay but then what happens is as you
know it to work out an average we and
what do we do with all this numbers atom
all together and divide by however many
measures you have and this is the number
we come up with yes yeah yeah okay now
there's a problem with this number in
that this number sort of gives us the
impression that we have more accuracy
then we really can actually measure okay
like it looks to this that we can get to
the tenths of a millimeter but we can't
no one can we're all using the same
instrument okay I mean I could have
gotten even more if I had more
measurements and taking the average I
could have like you know whatever
whatever all these different decimal
places but they're all just artificial
none of them could actually have been
measured with this instrument right so
therefore the answer wisely takes the
numbers all of the averages right I'm
sorry all scores and then therefore the
average and it rounds them now they've
chosen to round to this accuracy to zero
decimal places of accuracy why is that
the accuracy they're chosen it's not
it's not right it's not one it's not
like two significant figures
twice
because of all the other ones right
every other measurement that went into
here all of these guys these were all to
the nearest millimeter yeah
so therefore what this should be is also
to the nearest millimeter if you want to
think about it this way I want to
imagine if all of us right now measure
an object
okay and suppose you know 24 out of 25
months got this measurement and one
person not this one
now when you have a look at them when
you go ahead and you calculate the
average I expect because there's one
person who's slightly lower right there
will be an average of 250 4.99 whatever
whatever right because there's one
person who's slightly lower okay but
when we say like what are we trying to
get as the best measurement clearly this
is the best one all right
like almost everyone has measured this
and that's the accuracy of an actual
instrument okay so therefore you take
the average it is right to infer that we
have to approximate they don't tell you
to across of me
but the approximation is kind of implied
by what you used in the first place this
thing itself is approximate so the
approximation kind of comes along for
the ride does that make sense so you're
measuring to the nearest millimeter then
that's what you end up with when you're
sending me that will calm and whatever
it happens to be okay so I want you to
um if you've not finished those
questions yet just leave a little bit of
space and make this something okay
because this is kind of getting at the
same idea
limits of accuracy we talked about this
just a third category of error remember
that what were the other two countries
goodish Southern Miss of scale errors
which is like like parallax or big bad
scale and stars when you're not quite
you know beginning at zero okay so this
one's really important cuz you actually
have to do a bit of mathematical work I
want to introduce some terminologies
that language to you because when you've
got language when you've got terminology
you can describe a problem that you can
solve it so firstly we talk about what's
the limit of reading right what's the
closest most accurately you can read on
an actual instrument so what that means
is what that's equivalent to is the
smallest unit that's measured out we've
between millimeters and centimeters so
call this this
on the instrument
now therefore do you remember you were
looking at that sort of fictional ruler
there and I think it had like 13 14 15
something like that and then they place
it object on top and you might have had
it there now I think most of us who can
see woods closer to 13 than news to 14
it's somewhere between but I'm gonna go
ahead and round down because that's the
limit of reading on this object okay on
this instrument but it could have been
on either side like clearly it's not
exactly 13 so how far away would I have
to be from 13 to decide oh now it's
longer it's actually closer to 14 how
far would I have to go I have to go
exactly halfway right so if I had a new
object and instead it was like yeah okay
because I've passed that magic halfway
point I've said ah now it's closer than
that one it's still not exactly closest
to that but it's going to be know when
I'm rounding that's going to give me a
better result okay so therefore we
talked about this idea of we talked
about this idea of the greatest possible
error what's the farthest you could
actually be away from the real
measurement than it is right and you
guys told me it was about half way you
can either go a half way too long or
half way too short okay
so therefore what's the biggest area it
could be well you look at the limit of
reading and your Harvard you can go up
or down on that amount okay so the
greatest possible error will be half the
limit of reading don't get to the
possible - in a second and we'll mention
that you're very done this if I
therefore say okay I measure with this
thing and I say 13 centimeters right
it could be 13 or could be 13 foot 1 or
13
two or thirteen point four nine and I'd
still say 13 right I could go in the
other direction it could have been
twelve point nine or twelve point eight
or twelve point five one and I'd still
say it's closer to 13 right so what we
then say are the limits with the upper
and lower limits of true measurement
sorry should have so we've got the limit
of reading which is like we just look at
the unit's just tell me what the units
are you don't even need an object right
and then you've got what can you truly
measure it's gonna be half of those
units on either side right so we'd say
plus or minus their greatest possible
error and they used the acronym GPD for
that you sometimes also see AE which
means absolute error which means exactly
the same thing so maybe I'll put that
okay so you've got the GPE in the AE
which are actually the same thing just
different names so on here
we'd say okay the limits of true
measurement on this thing are plus or
minus half a centimeter okay so this
object that I've measured and I've told
you it's 13 it could be anywhere 13 plus
or minus that half a centimeter so 12.5
to 13.5 does that make sense okay now
where this is eventually going is not
just having an absolute error like in
centimeters or millimeters or whatever
unit you like but was they called
percentage error now this is actually
quite tricky it's so tricky it makes a
bunch of a formula and data sheet it's
not something we're going to get to
today because I gave you all of the
exercises before this so just know
that's on its way in sort of the second
half or the third third of this exercise
but this idea of limits of accuracy of
be able to say okay what's the unit once
plus or minus half of that can I take
some measurements on whatever instrument
I've got that's what the next part of to
is